okay good underneath this place and
you're working could you draw for me a
new set of axes again please use your
ruler this whole discussion of scale
becomes very very difficult if you don't
have something accurate to work off so
this is one
[Music]
now we're going to do this one faster
because you know a lot about this shape
already on the basis of the previous one
that you did right so before we start
launching to this right one of the
things that's really important is
whenever you look at a new mathematical
problem you connect it to and I don't
mean this is an exaggeration you
connected to every mathematical problem
you have ever solved before because all
the things the principles in knowledge
you gain in there will help you here and
it just so happens we just did a problem
here which is highly relevant to this
one over here but there are some
important differences and that's why I'm
doing it as own thing and not messing it
up in the same graph what's the
difference between this graph and that
one yet either okay it's been shifted
vertically one unit downwards do you
agree with that okay so in some sense is
what I could do is I could just take
this shape and I could just redraw it
all over again over here okay and in
some senses that will be what I do but I
want to think about this through the
lens and how we did this before before
we started looking for like intercepts
right so for example if I think about
the first thing I'm gonna write this I'm
gonna search for a y-intercept violating
X equal zero right
so when x equals zero I'm going to get y
equals look carefully I'm gonna do the
substitution so that I know which one
I'm talking about right because I don't
want to lean on my instincts if I'm not
100% confident so I'm gonna go zero
cubed minus one and that's negative one
yeah you carry that so that's my
y-intercept say that again well this is
a point where I worry about too much
right now but the short answer is
negative is an adjective it's a thing
you used to describe things like a
number that number is a negative number
minus is actually an operation it's
something that happens between two
numbers in our brains they mostly feel
the same but Java can I borrow your
calculator
say yours yeah you might actually notice
maybe you never noticed on your
calculator there is a minus button it's
that one down here with the plus and the
multiplication in the division that's a
minus button it operates between two
numbers and then did you ever notice
there was like a little minus button up
in the top it's between brackets did you
notice that
that's the negative button that's a
negative number now it just so happens
that you know when you subtract
something it's the same as adding it if
it were negative but that's why you'll
hear me saying negative one because
that's a number not an operation what
point am I going to put onto my graph as
a consequence of this zero comma
negative one right so I'm doing this to
myself so I remember where this goes on
the graph so this is a y-intercept so
I'm going to put that there
okay now I've only found a y-intercept
over here when I did this one I found an
x-intercept and y-intercept at the same
time it's kind of like oh that's nice a
bit of a bonus but I have not found a
y-intercept at the moment so sorry I've
not found an x-intercept so I need to
find one if this is how I find a
y-intercept how do I find an x-intercept
then y equals zero it's a when y equals
zero and I'm just gonna do the same
substitution that I did before right so
I'm gonna say zero equals x cubed minus
one you can see it's gone into the Y
right so I can add one to both sides and
I'm gonna switch the sides while I'm at
it because the X is the thing I'm
focused on and what's the number that I
multiply by itself three times to get
one do you agree that okay so I can now
put a different point on to my axes fit
onto my Cartesian plane for this there's
the x coordinate there's a y coordinate
right so that's one comma zero right
which is here which corresponds to do
you remember we found this point 1 1
right we found that on this graph but
what we've done is we've taken
everything here and we've moved it down
as Ian suggested one unit vertically
okay so you can see I'm gonna get this
shape here and it's just going to be
like what it was before except as you
pointed out it's one unit lower okay Y
and X and I've been a bit naughty I've
been leaving off each of these times we
should label what the equation is as
well so that's y equals x cubed
okay now just before we leave off this
right these graphs are okay and there's
a few thing two things to point out the
first one is do you notice for both of
these and for all of the graphs are we
looking at right the graph kind of is
steep in some points and it's I'm
shallow at others did you notice that
right like the gradient of our line it
changes that's different to our our
linear graphs it's just always the same
gradient everywhere now you might notice
there's this special spot on both of
these graphs where the gradient is not
too shallow if you take your ruler which
I don't have I'm gonna pinch your relax
man thank you if you take your ruler
right and you place it right across that
spot there in this case it actually
happens to be the x-axis over here it's
not the x-axis it's dissapoint here okay
it's kind of like the the steepness of
the graph kind of stops momentarily
stops and then it goes back up okay all
right now kind of but not really now I'm
gonna introduce some language here that
won't be as relevant until later but I
think it's helpful for you to know so
you can talk about this spot this spot
here and on this one here this spot here
because it's like if you can imagine
like a man or a car sort of like running
driving up running up and then getting
to this point and then going off right
this point here is sort of like where it
stops for a brief moment and then it
keeps going right we call that point
going with the idea or something
stopping and being motionless we call it
a stationary point stationary with an a
as opposed to stationary with an e like
this is stationary and this is
stationary this is a stationary point
and it's really important when you graph
this that the graph at that little
moment in time is flat okay it's not
kind of at an angle it's literally flat
okay if we were to draw this line
through that should be a tangent it
should have the same gradient there okay
now this word he really or this phrase
rather becomes really important when we
dig into calculus so this is actually
calculus language but because we're
dealing with these graphs really need to
be able to describe that point and I
rather give it a name the name that
you're going to have later rather than
say it's that point that looks kind of
flat we have a word for it we might as
well use it okay
stationary point now one last thing
before we have a look at the next one
I'm gonna start to rub this one off and
you can start to drop your next your
third set of axes one of the things you
might notice about both of these graphs
is they both have X intercepts right
you're like of course they have X
intercepts why wouldn't they have X's
intercepts and I'm gonna ask you that
question why wouldn't they have X
intercepts because you know we were
looking at these other shapes before
right before cubics we were looking at
not power 3 power 2 they're called
parabolas cred quadratics tray and they
don't always have EXA desserts right
they don't always have them why not cuz
that's how this first e wrassle were you
thinking ah okay so we know that
parabolas have that vertex right like
the bottom of the graph so it could look
something like this like so and it turns
never it never comes close to the axis
or it could do this on the other side
right do you remember we gave these
names when the discriminant is negative
and like you get a graph and it's always
above or it's always below do you mean
what we call that we use the word
definite do you remember that we call
this positive definite and negative
definite okay but cubics can't do this
did you notice that cubic can't possibly
be always above or always below qmix
will always go sort of between both
right and therefore they must always
cross they must always cost every single
time so you always get an x intercept
and y intercept for a cubic